cómo
por favor
y estoy muy emocionada de estar aquí
agradecida
bueno por lo regular cuando estoy en
frente a una multitud número uno lleva
un traje de baño muy apretada
número 2 estoy parada en una plataforma
de 20 metros de altura en un lugar
bellísimo pero a la vez es aterrador
número 3
trató de regular mi respiración y de
contener los nervios y la adrenalina
número 4 me dirijo a la plataforma a la
orilla de la plataforma
y me convenzo de que realmente quiero
estar y ya una vez convencida de que
quiere estar ahí quiero saltar llevando
los brazos
me repito tres veces lo que tengo que
hacer específicamente en el clavado del
agua y salto
y lo sentí muy real
pero allí es muy distinto hoy me
encuentro aquí frente a ustedes no llevo
un traje de baño estoy más cómoda puedo
verlos a los ojos y sobre todo por
compartirles
cómo es que los clavados de altura me
han ayudado a descubrir la brújula de mi
vida y también me pusieron en el camino
correcto y me han también dado muchas
experiencias y satisfacciones quiero
compartir con ustedes todas las
satisfacciones que he tenido a lo largo
de mi carrera
por lo regular también muchas personas
me dicen cómo es que llegaste a los
clavos de altura esa pregunta siempre me
la me la hacen y también qué hago con el
miedo de estar parada y arriba qué hago
con ese miedo bueno la número uno cómo
es que llegan los clavos de altura es
una historia muy larga pero voy a tratar
de reducirlo un poco
la verdad no estaba en mis planes no
estaba en mi diario no estaba en mi
agenda y tampoco yo de niña yo soñaba
con aventarme desde tan alto no sé a
quién en su sano juicio va a querer
dedicarse es a quién
y la verdad es que la vida me puso ahí
la vida y el destino porque porque no se
recorre cta mente un ciclo que debí
cerrar con la frente en alto yo pasé por
muchas disciplinas desde niña desde los
4 años karate natación clavados fui
porrista también por ahí y cada una de
esas actividades me preparo para pararme
en esa plataforma y cada uno de esos
entrenadores me ayudaron con su
experiencia y sus conocimientos a
fortalecer medio estar lista y eso fue
alrededor de 26 años más o menos
pero
la disciplina de los clavados
tradicionales me dejó ese mal sabor de
boca que me hizo regresar a estos
clavados porque cuando yo tenía 19 años
tenía 11 años de carrera y muchos años
de pertenecer a la selección nacional
de clavados
debido a que no clasifique a los juegos
olímpicos de atenas-2004 decidí
retirarme ya no quise luchar
quería saber qué había más allá de una
plataforma de una alberca tenía mucha
curiosidad a los 19 años y me metí a
estudiar obviamente tuve amigos novios y
estás padrísimo no lo disfruté bastante
pero siempre me quedó esa espinita de
que hubiera pasado si hubiera luchado y
hubiera luchado por ese pasa juegos
olímpicos que al final lo gane pero se
le otorgaban a alguien más porque lo
gane para méxico y no para mí y eso es
siempre un problema en el deporte en fin
tuve amigos tuve novios tuve fiestas me
gustó mucho pero siempre me vea me el
hubiera me atormentaba dicen que lo
hubiera no existe pero si existe y
existe para atormentar t
entonces más que atormentarme yo me
debía algo terminé mi carrera y empecé a
trabajar mi primer trabajo fue como
entrenadora de clavadas la vida se hizo
presente y me dijo vuelves a los
clavados de esta manera como entrenadora
años después me rodeado de personas que
se dedican a los clavos de altura y me
ofrecen un show de clavados en bélgica
yo no sabía no tenía ni idea de lo que
era eso simplemente dije si quería
aventurar me quería saber qué era lo que
pasaba que era lo que iba a pasar
y me fui a un show de clouds en bélgica
donde aprendí a tirarme clavados de más
de 10 metros de altura para esto ya
habían pasado más de 7 años y entidad
clavados y mi cuerpo sabía cómo hacer
las cosas después de 7 años de no haber
tirado clavados mi cuerpo tenía memoria
mi cabeza sabía lo que lo que iba a
hacer y poco a poco sin presión sin
llenar expectativas de nadie
sin querer darle gusto a nadie empecé a
aprender a tirarme un poquito más de 10
metros 10 12 15 17 y un día volteó y la
torre donde yo trabajaba los 20 metros
está ahí inicio porque no no simplemente
quería saber qué era lo que se encendía
se clavaba por favor les presento a mi
primer clavo de altura de mi vida corre
vídeo por favor el vídeo corto
lograba uno de mis compañeritos
yo solamente quería tirarme por
curiosidad sabía que lo tenía que hacer
lento sabía que iba a ser algo único en
mi vida pero nunca sabía que ese clavado
me iba a abrir las puertas a todo lo que
he vivido el día de hoy
y ahí cayó al agua
cuando caiga lo hago a salvo la
superficie dije mi carrera deportiva no
terminada apenas va a comenzar de ahí
comencé a ser un poco más ejecuciones
envié mi vídeo para la serie mundial
y en la actualidad son la primera
mexicana soy la pionera de este deporte
en practicar los clavos de altura y no
sólo eso hemos competido a nivel mundial
anne oro en la copa del mundo plata en
el campeonato mundial y está rankeada en
segundo lugar con red bull cliff diving
no lo imaginaba
y la verdad agradezco mucho todas estas
experiencias y estos momentos únicos así
es cómo llegué a los clavos de altura
yo no quise estar ahí la vida me puso
ahí para que para aprender a luchar por
algo que no termine
con la frente en alto y como tenía que
haberlo terminado siempre la vida los va
a regresar tal vez
no al mismo lugar pero si en una
situación muy similar para que para que
actúe te muevas y cambios toda esa
perspectiva yo tenía que estar parada en
un podio yo no me podía ir de los clavos
ni en el deporte sin
[Música]
sin ofrecerle a mi país más
oportunidades para que los jóvenes sigan
creciendo esa ha sido mi misión y la
pregunta número dos que siempre me han
hecho que es qué hago con el miedo
recuerdo que de niña me diseño ama
así que sé por qué es que tienes miedo
que es el miedo es el miedo de qué color
es no para mí no lo veo pero lo siento
lo siento el miedo es el temor a lo
desconocido a lo desconocido eso que no
sabes qué va a pasar a eso es a lo que
le temes
pero les tengo una buena noticia el
miedo no es malo al contrario el miedo
te pone alerta
el miedo agudiza tus sentidos
y el miedo te pone en acción
ustedes creen que ya no me da miedo al
tirarme de 20 metros
me da miedo no me da miedo
me da muchísimo miedo
pero he aprendido a controlarlo y lo he
hecho mi mejor aliado a todos los
clavadistas nos da miedo tirarnos porque
el miedo también hace que respetemos la
altura al respetar la altura preparamos
tres veces más para poder disfrutar de
tu clavado
ese es el miedo y cómo se enfrenta el
miedo exponiéndote a él una y otra y
otra vez exponiéndote a él enfrentando
lo cara cara y haciendo eso que tanto
temes una y otra vez para mí
se me ha facilitado mucho y ha aprendido
a controlarlo visualizando visualizando
me en esa plataforma haciendo mis
clavados una y otra vez y la
visualización tiene que ser lo más real
posible como caminas sentir tu cuerpo
escuchar las olas del mar escuchar lo
que está en el ambiente los olores
también entre más real sea tu
visualización va a ser mejor porque
porque el cerebro no capta qué es lo
real y qué es lo que no está sucediendo
entonces para ti ya sucedió ese momento
eso a mí me funcionaba mucho para poder
controlar este miedo para las alturas
sigamos
y cómo se controla tener el miedo
preparándote bien si tú te preparas bien
para eso que viene
el miedo se va a unir contigo y lo va a
hacer contigo
por ejemplo
cada que yo entreno entreno a conciencia
entreno con un propósito y un motivo no
hago cientos de clavados al día
solamente por cumplir con mi programa de
entrenamiento no cada clavado lo tengo
que hacer a conciencia sabiendo qué es
lo que va a ser mi cuerpo mi mente mi
cuerpo tienen que estar conectados
porque porque si estás haciendo algo
pero tu mente está en otra parte no hay
conexión y de nada sirve porque porque
no lo pidas porque no vas a tener amor
al hacerlo y el resultado no va a ser el
mejor no hacer el óptimo entonces
siempre tienes que estar en contacto
contigo tienes que hacerlo a conciencia
con mucho amor y sobre todo con un
motivo el motivo que ustedes quieran ya
sea
sus papás el ex su cross su perro el
motivo que ustedes quieran ustedes
eligen el motivo pero ese motivo tiene
que estar ahí diario cuando se
despiertan y cuando se duerme
estamos
bueno
también prepararse
el esfuerzo es muy importante pero el
prepararse con disciplina todos los días
si funciona pero funciona también
preparar tu mente y tu corazón
bolt en saber si cada uno de ustedes
somos distintos cada uno
y así como yo descubrí que tenía talento
para hacer clavados de altura
cada uno de ustedes así como son
distintos físicamente
también son distintos en las cualidades
que cada uno posee
unos son buenos para la cocina yo no
otros son buenos para la música
otros son buenos para el arte para el
deporte pero cada uno de nosotros somos
auténticos únicos e irrepetibles y cada
uno de nosotros tenemos que descubrir
cuál es el don que tenemos cuál es el
don que se nos ha enviado y tenemos que
desarrollarlo de manera responsable y
con mucho amor
porque porque si no se hace eso nunca
van a poder descubrir lo que realmente
les apasiona lo que realmente les gusta
y para lo que estamos hechos es un
martirio dedicarte algo que no te gusta
a mí no me gusta realmente sentir todo
ese medio es adrenalina y esa presión
pero cuántas mujeres en este país lo
hacen
eso me hace única e irrepetible es un
mensaje que me da la vida de que yo
tengo que estar ahí porque
porque va a ser voy a hacer la punta de
lanza para muchas jóvenes no solo
clavadistas en el deporte de que no hay
imposibles
yo no sabía de lo que era capaz hasta
que me puse en esa plataforma y decidí
en que yo quería hacerla mejor
decidí en que no importaba cuánto miedo
sintiera o cuántos nervios sintiera yo
era capaz de dominar mi mente mi cuerpo
para hacer esos clavados como yo quería
hacerlos de manera perfecta aún sigo
buscando esa perfección no sé si la voy
a lograr pero lo que sí sé es que quiero
dejar huella en este país para los
jóvenes porque en sus manos está mi país
y yo todos los días cierro los ojos y me
imagino la bandera de mi país ondeando
con esos tres hermosos colores y yo su
vida
en el podio en el primer lugar no sé si
vaya a pasar pronto no sé si vaya a
pasar después pero lo que sí estoy
segura
es que así como yo todos tenemos que
sentirnos orgullosos de dónde venimos de
dónde de nuestras raíces y de que los
mexicanos con pocos recursos que tenemos
siempre hemos salido adelante siempre
hemos estado de frente
exponiéndonos a eso que tanto le tememos
y nos solidarizamos y siempre sacamos
las dudas adelante yo no sé ustedes pero
yo si quiero marcar la diferencia yo los
invito a que por favor descubran ese don
que se les dio a desarrollarlo con mucho
amor
con muchísima responsabilidad los invito
también a que sueñen alto porque el
límite es el cielo muchísimas gracias
soñar generar sonrisas y disfrutar al
máximo la vida soy adriana jiménez la
vista de altura campeona y subcampeona
mundial desde la plataforma de los 20
metros cinta negro en karate y licencia
de la administración del deporte cada
clavado me inspira a sentirme viva plena
estoy orgullosa de ser mexicana y ser
parte de esta cultura
hablamos de nuestros sueños algo
tangible que puedas sentir tocar y
porque para mí y para los mexicanos
no hay imposible
[Música]
[Aplausos]
me quedan 30 segundos quiero agradecer a
todos los que hicieron esto posible y
sobre todo lo mejor que me ha dejado los
lados de altura son las personas que me
rodean gracias a gustaba alpuche por la
oportunidad porque gracias a él estoy
aquí y bueno muchísimas gracias y mucho
amor para todos
[Aplausos]